[There's] a lot of interesting stuff both from the
point of view of the content but also
the historical context between, y' know
"When were `for' loops invented?". Well
that's what Algol called them but prior
to that FORTRAN called them DO loops.
And prior to that they existed in assembler.
So, first of all, what's the history and
what does it get you when you can do
loops, but when do you run out of steam,
even with loops, and you have to use this
shock! horror! Pure Mathematicians thing -
that computer scientists have to learn
about - recursion?! It was a real culture
shock, it really was, in the roughly
1940s, 1950s to suddenly find
out that what the theoreticians had been
drivelling on about for years - about recursive
functions in mathematics - actually was of
massive, massive importance for computer
science. Back in the '40s and early
'50s it was all Assembler - or a
slightly dressed-up thing called a macro
assembler, where you can have little
routines full of, y' know, packaged
assembler instructions which could be
called up, as and when needed. So, that
sort of served people for quite some
time. But probably one of the first
high-level languages to introduce loops
was good old FORTRAN [shows textbook]. Even though
that was published in '65 Fortran itself goes
back, I think, for almost ten years before
that. It was invented by John Backus and
a large team of people at IBM in the
1950s. Many of you will know it. It's an
excellent language for engineering and
scientific calculations. It is low level.
I mean, when you look at the nature of a
FORTRAN loop it's almost like doing it
in assembler - but not quite. They didn't
call them for loops - they called them DO loops.
What I'm saying here is - you package all this
up - where you're saying
repeat the following sequence of
instructions, which I've done with my
wavy lines here. Keep doing them until
you hit the statement with a numeric
label on it of 180. The loop back from
the statement labelled 180, back up to
here to increment the loop counter, which
you're all familiar with in languages
like C. It wasn't done, as it would
be in C, by saying: "Here's my block of
stuff to be repeated it's inside these
curly braces". Here you can see it's a lot
more like assembler, a lot more low-level.
I mean there's nothing magic about "180"; it could
be "72"; it depended on your labelling
system. Implicitly here, in a simple
thing like this, you'd start off [with the counter]
at one and every time I returned back here it would
reset [the counter] to be 2, 3, 4 and so on up to
and including 10. It's comforting for
those who were coming from assembler
into a higher-level language to see
something that was only slightly higher
level, in sophistication, than assembler was.
How did loops become more "powerful",
if you like?
Well, again, even in assembler and even in
FORTRAN, there's no reason why you
couldn't have a loop within a loop. So I
might have, outside of all this code, yet
another layer of DO. What shall we say:
"DO 200 J = 1, 20". So, there might
be some more statements between 180 and
200, who knows, but again, you see, a
numeric label. And can see what's
happening is that for every setting of J,
which will start at 1 and go up to 20,
for every single one of those J settings
the inner loop will be running through
the complete spectrum of settings of I
going from 1 to 10. So you will have 200
locations [that] are being affected here.
Basically going through the rows and
columns of a matrix. All sorts of
calculations in physics, chemistry and
particularly engineering just rely on
two-dimensional arrays full of numbers
- either integers or scientific numbers
with a decimal point. and so on. Even hard-core
assembly programmers had to admit if you were
doing heavy scientific programming it was
nice to be a little bit more abstract
and to have this sort of facility
available to you. Now you might say: "Well,
what came along to spoil the party then ?"
or "How did people realize that this was
wonderful but not quite enough?"
The compiler of course has got to be
tolerant and has got to be capable of
compiling nested DO loops correctly but
how deep would it let you nest them?
Well, I'm guessing, I would suspect that
the early FORTRAN compilers probably
wouldn't allow you to go more than about
10 deep, maximum. And I think you and I
Sean have just been looking up what are the
current limits in C?  I seem to remember
the earliest `gcc' was something like 32
But Ithink we looked up this ... some C++
nowadays allows you to do nested loops
256 deep! And, of course, there are
multi-dimensional problems that might
actually need that, because it it doesn't
take much knowledge of higher maths to
realize if you've got a loop within a loop
the outer loop goes around n times; the
inner loop is going around n times, you
are then coping with an n-squared
problem. If you put the third loop inside
the other two you're coping with a cubic,
three-dimensional, problem. So what we're
saying is all these multi-dimensional
polynomial-going-on-exponential problems,
that come up quite naturally, you can
cope with them in nested for-loops so
long as they don't need to be more than
power-32 or power-256 or whatever it is.
And you think, well, that should be enough for
anybody! There's these multi-dimensional
problems you can just do them by nesting
`for' loops and surely [a depth of] 256 is
enough for anybody? What kind of problem
wouldn't it be enough for? Well, a lot of
theoretical computer scientists of my
knowledge amused me greatly when - those of
them that will own up to this - back in
the 60s. People started going to lectures
from mathematicians, theoreticians, people concerned
with "Godel Computability" and so on. And
of course, those sort of people, were very
familiar indeed, at a mathematical level,
with Ackermann's function. Now, as you know -
you and I - we've done that one:
>> Sean: Was that "The most difficult ... ?"
>> DFB: "The most difficult number to compute, question mark"
<Ackermann video insert>
"We set this going four weeks ago
nearly now the first few are vanished ..."
</Ackermann video insert>
So what made it so difficult?
well you write down Ackermann's function and
it very clearly ends up with routines
calling themselves recursively in a very
very complicated way. Now I think your
average sort of engineer would be happy
to say that there's this thing called `factorial'
which is 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1,
or whatever. And you could do that in a
loop as well as doing this fancy
recursion thing, but a lot of
theoreticians admitted to me they saw a
Ackermann's function and said: "I could try that
out in FORTRAN !". Now what they perhaps
didn't realize - but it became famous by 1960 - is:
FORTRAN is wonderful, but original
FORTRAN did not do user-level recursion
You could write a thing called ACK.
You could actually get it to call itself
in FORTRAN. But you might have been
expecting that every time it called
itself it would lay out a data area for
each recursive call they're called "stack
frames" - we know that now. You get lots of
stack frames, one on top of another and
as you come back through the recursion
they're deleted and thrown away and you
climb back into your main program.
FORTRAN doesn't do that. It sets
aside one stack frame. You keep calling
yourself recursively it just tramples
in its muddy gumboots over all your
data area and you end up with total
garbage. It no more gives you values of the
Ackermann function than fly to the moon!
And people said: "I then realized the
importance of having user-level
recursion, in programming languages, to
cope with those really hard problems
that fell outside nested for-loops".
Algol was famous in that its routines
could call themselves recursively and
could get the right answer and, for
limited low-order values of Ackermann's
function - very slow, very slow indeed - but
it would come out with the right answer.
>> Sean: Is there any need to think of an example of a
problem, or program, because Ackermann
feels to me like it's the test-bed.
You know, when you're testing out a
motor-car you might take it on the track
and see how fast it can go.
But in day-to-day life that car might
only get half that speed. What's the
real-world kind of equivalent? Is there
such a thing?
>> DFB: Real world equivalent?
>> Sean: ... of something that might need to use
recursion ... ?
>> DFB: ... of that complexity? Not many things
is the answer to that. I mean, yes, it's
true that Ackermann, as you know, was David
Hilbert's research student. And the
challenge was on to find something that
was so innately recursive that - remember
it was "generally recursive", they called it -
as opposed to "primitive recursive". And
simple things like factorial and indeed
indeed Fibonacci, are primitive recursive.
So I think you're right that you really
are just making the point that
eventually there are things that will
kill you. I think the question in the
middle is: "Is there something out there -
pieces of program you need to write -
where non-trivial recursion, in a sense,
is needed but not quite to the
horrendous degree that Ackermann did. And the
answer is:  "Yes, compilers is where it hit
people".  Because although early FORTRAN
did not provide user-level recursion, for
you and me, nevertheless John Backus and
his team implemented it in the middle
1950s I think at IBM.
And Backus wrote articles afterwards
basically saying: "We didn't know enough
about recursion and even though we
didn't provide it for the users of our
language, boy did we need it in the
compiler! And
we ended up inventing it in all but name"
The syntactic structures of what is
legal, in a language, even at the level
just of arithmetic statements can be
quite recursive. Because you end up with
brackets within brackets within brackets
all with a multiplier outside. And which
order do you do the brackets in? And, you
know, how how many levels of bracket
nesting can you have. And if you don't
get things sorted out correctly then
you'll get the wrong answer. But once again
the problem could be that your users
would come up to you and present you
with a problem just designed to test out
your compiler, and whether it was robust
enough to be able to cope with a high
degree of nesting even just in
arithmetic statements. So by 1960 in
Algol, yeah, the there were enough users, at
the user level, who could see that a
modicum of recursion, perhaps more
complicated than factorial but not quite
up to full Ackermann capabilities would be
very nice indeed to have within your language.
<trailer for EXTRA BITS video>
Again referring back to that
original video, I had a lot of really
interesting mail from various people who
said to me: "OK, you said that this is an
innately recursive problem and it just
had to have general recursion capabilities?
Well I .... "
</end of trailer>